hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the video World rapid
Championship it is Magnus Carlson versus
badham maksudu and Magnus is fighting
for first place going into the final
round Magnus cross and Vincent kymer and
vladislavartamev are tied for uh for
first place with nine points and uh uh
all of them can still go to 10 uh to 10
points and uh if there is a if there is
a tie there will be a playoff so it's
not like uh there's a tie and then
additional criteria is being checked to
see who will win first place so if it's
a tie then there will be a playoff now
uh Magnus has the white pieces here
let's check out what happened and then
we are going to discuss as it was
incredibly dramatic not just on this
board but on many other boards regarding
uh who wins the tournament so Magnus
with the white pieces opens with E4 we
have C5 by Maxwell Knight to F3 D6 and
the D4 Magnus opens up the at the center
he goes for the uh open uh well uh the
the Open Line captures captures and now
Knight to F6 we have knighted the C3 and
now the question is which uh Sicilian
will yeah maxulu opt for will he go for
the dragon maybe for this evening and
maybe for the night or but no he goes
for Knight to C6 this is the classical
variation of the Sicilian and what
better way to challenge the world
classical Champion Magnus Carlsen so
here Bishop to G5 now of course they
will have to test out each other's uh
Theory knowledge E6 with Queen to D2 and
now A6 we have Castles by Magnus uh
Bishop to D7 and pawn to F3 now now
Magnus can start pushing on uh on the
king side if black castles King side
Knight captures on D4 we have Queen
captures and now Bishop to E7 so uh it's
now fairly obvious we will see a castles
of opposite sides or maybe Maxwell's
King will remain the center but Maxwell
should try pushing on the queen side
whereas Magnus will start pushing on the
king side and this is the kind of one
the kind of game that you need uh yeah
when you're fighting for first place and
you need a win in the final round so
King B1 of course always a useful
prophylactic move Pawn to B5 with H4
Magnus starts pushing on the king side
Rook to B8 we have G for now and now
Pawn to B4 chasing away the knight from
a C3 Knight back to E2 and there is a
game where Queen the A5 was played but
here we have the immediate Pawn to A5
and it is now as of move 14 that we have
a completely new game Magnus goes to G3
with his Knight and now Queen to C7 with
Bishop back to E3 now opening up uh the
the G5 Square for the pawn and Rook the
C8 and here uh as the C2 Pawn is hanging
Magnus uh instantly played Rook to H2
but there is a very very tricky move
here that he could have played and that
is Bishop to A6 this is just a slap in
the face for your opponent as you are
laughing uh because it shows how Rook to
see it is not the greatest of moves um
problem is if you move the Rook where
where you move the Rook if you move the
Rook then you move the bishop and then
The Rook returns to the original square
and then well we we just want a tempo
for our Bishop so now it's like white
won a free move and and the other thing
um if you play Queen captures on C2 not
just King to A1 and there is nothing
here for black now uh The Rook is still
hanging and if Rook date then again
Bishop to D3 and now if you move the
queen G5 and where is the Knight going
so it would be very very hard to escape
this if Magnus spotted Bishop to A6 but
here Rook to H2 was played with D5 now
and the Magnus closes the center with E5
we have castles now uh as if e Captain
it's a very complicated line in fact if
e-catra is an F6 Queen captures and G3
but not right away first you will play
Bishop characters and F6 attack the
White Queen and now look at this bishop
to F4 attacks the black queen and now E5
attacks the White Queen and now just
Knight the H5 so absolute madness here I
mean everything is hanging even the C2
Pawn is still hanging and here we would
see e captures on the four Knight
captures and F6 which check G captures
Bishop captures and C7 Rook captures and
Rook captures on D4 and we would have
this end game with equal material uh
with white having a slightly better Pawn
structure so that's why after Castle's e
captures an F6 uh well it is a a a a
nice move there is a better one and now
Magnus spots it the bishop to A6 still
works uh so the The Rook now has to move
uh the The Rook here guards the C2 uh
Pawn or even in that other line yeah I
sort of uh said that it it uh it is
still possible but yeah uh Rook to H2
defends that even I missed that so here
Rook to A8 attacks the bishop Bishop
back to D3 now puts a lot of pressure on
Black's King side and now Rook F the C8
and now Magnus uh plays Queen to F4 now
this is a threat because the queen is
now uh blocking the the black queens the
reach of the Knight on G3 Knight the E8
and now Pawn to G5 we give Bishop to C5
and here Magnus traits captures captures
and he pushes H5 so this is now a race
for for the World Chess Championship
title uh Bishop to B5 and now uh there
is one move that truly crushes Black's
defenses so feel free to pause the video
and win the game for Magnus while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations as you are now a
world rapid champion and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop characters on H7 with check
King captures an H7 and now Pawn to G6
uh really nothing for you to do uh
f-captress and G6 and now Magnus even
doesn't Rush with age captures on G6 he
plays Queen to F7 uh and now there
really is nothing to do H captains and
G6 will be Checkmate this is mating one
so G5 was played but now just Pawn to H6
and he was in this position on the Move
28 that Magnus Carlsen won the game and
with the title of world rapid Champion
so Abdu satra was not able to defend uh
Magnus wins first place and there's some
the other games are still being played
while I'm recording this I still don't
know who won uh second and third but I
will inform you guys at some point so
truly incredible and regarding what was
happening on other boards our team have
also had a chance if he defeated Fabiano
Cortana for a playoff against Magnus but
karon not defeated him and the third
game which was an absolute Thriller
Maxim vashilagra versus Vincent kymer
Vincent kymer with the black pieces had
a chance to defeat Maxine Marshall Agra
it was a grueling game very hard game he
outplayed him and then he had a win but
he was uh I mean you would have to find
um it's something that definitely
belongs in a in a book about end games
uh had he had he found a win in that end
game he would be challenging Magnus to a
playoff but uh mvl defended well and uh
Magnus was very happy as he was standing
next to the Border when it was being
played uh mvl defended and that means
that Magnus Carlsen is now the uh well
the reigning world rapid Champion uh so
yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it now with all this uh rapid
stuff being over we are switching on to
the little bit section I will check a
few more games to see uh maybe a nice
game to show I I definitely have one
that I think you guys will enjoy but if
you have any other favorites do
suggestion and I will go over it so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it uh in this short coverage of the
world rapid Championship we are now
switching to Blitz I would like to thank
David rocks rice Oxley Kevin Clark Chris
Mullen rapidboss and Michael Hoff uh
Consulting for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the V8 World
Blitz Championship as it starts tomorrow
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day